bonsoir c'est une situation toujours
inquiétante en tunisie qui vient donc de
passer en rouge alors que les aides
internationales se multiplient notamment
depuis la france bonjour stéphanie
effectivement c'est une quatrième vague
assez compliquée qui essaye de gérer le
gouvernement tunisien avec un nombre de
décès qui explose le ms parle même d'un
taux de décès le plus élevé de tout le
continent africain
on a plus de 100 morts par jour c'est
vraiment énorme et c'est un maximum
atteint depuis le début de cette crise
du corona a bien lu ce un système de
santé au bord de l'implosion de
personnel de santé en appelle au
gouvernement qui pour utile puisse
prendre ses responsabilités et surtout
qu'ils puissent fournir aux hôpitaux le
matériel nécessaire pour pouvoir
travailler gérer tous ces patients de
renaissance des cadeaux pour la virus
une recrudescence des cas de
contamination du nord au sud personne
n'est épargné son ensemble du pays
malgré certains dispositifs mis en place
par le gouvernement notamment en termes
de restriction le grand tunis est
complètement isolé pendant le week-end
le couvre-feu est maintenu et puis il ya
des interdictions de circuler certains
gouvernorats sont même toujours en
confinement total la tunisie qui est
déjà pas passée en rouge pour beaucoup
de pays notamment framboise un alibi qui
vient de fermer à ses frontières si le
tour de la france qui a déclaré la
tunisie sur sa liste rouge
l'interdiction de rentrer ou de sortir
du territoire s'en trouvait être
vaccinés ou alors justifier d'un motif
impérieux ces quelques éléments aux
capus déclaré le porte parole du
gouvernement garder la tête propose de
l'écouter en raison de la dégradation
sanitaire en tunisie ce pays va
désormais être classé sur la liste rouge
cela signifie que pour les non vaccinés
on ne pourra s'y rendre en revenir sans
motif impérieux qu'un test négatif de -2
48 heures sera exigé pour les personnes
qui viennent en france et qu'un
isolement sera obligatoire à l'arrivée
un isolement de dix jours contrôlez vous
le savez pour tous les pays de la liste
rouge par les forces de l'ordre avec une
verbalisation de 1000 euros pour les
personnes qui ne respecteraient pas cet
isolement répondu stéphanie la tunisie
craignaient de voir arriver à cette
situation à ce cas de figure ce scénario
la tunisie parce qu'en rouge notamment
avec
france vu qu'on est au début de l'été
qu'il ya une porte qui aspirent à
tunisiana ta vie en france qui
comptaient venir passer ses vacances ici
de nouvelles restrictions alors que le
gouvernement peine toujours à gérer
cette recrudescence de coronavirus et
bassem la campagne vaccinale qui devrait
enfin s'accélérer la tunisie qui a
commencé à recevoir de nombreux dons en
provenance de plusieurs pays le
président même annoncé que l'armée
allait participer à cette opération de
vaccination effectivement stéphanie
c'est lors d'une réunion de crise qui
avait été organisée à carthage en
présence du président de la république
du ministre de la santé du chef de
l'état majeur et puis du directeur de
l'institut pasteur qui oeuvrent à
trouver des solutions notamment à
développer des vaccins ici en tunisie me
suis rendu compte que vraiment la
campagne de vaccination avait du mal à
décoller en tunisie notamment par le
scepticisme de certains tunisiens mais
surtout et surtout par le manque de
vaccins qu'il y a en tunisie malgré le
fait que le gouvernement essaie de
multiplier ses partenariats avec les
pays étrangers
mais l'heure est aux dons le
gouvernement tunisien appelle vraiment
la communauté internationale à envoyer
des dons et notamment à sa diaspora
établie à l'étranger d'envoyer notamment
des respirateurs au niveau des vaccins
on est très peu on est très loin tu te
retrouves % de la population seulement a
reçu une première dose 5% avons reçu une
seconde dose pour une population totale
de 12 millions d'habitants le ministre
de la santé a même annoncé que des
paroissiens pourront bientôt vacciner
dans les deux mêmes pour l'armée l'armée
qui peut vacciner et l'armée a déjà
commencé à vacciner notamment dans le
sud de pays dans la commune de tataouine
et je vous propose d'écouter un des
militaires qui oeuvrent à cette campagne
de vaccination dans le cadre de l'effort
national et sur instruction du
commandant suprême des forces armées le
président de la république
le ministère tunisien de la défense et
l'administration générale de la santé
militaire
afin d'intensifier et de vacciner le
plus grand nombre possible de citoyens
les citoyens n'ont d'autre choix que de
se faire vacciner alors vous l'avez vu à
ceux des paniers même les militaires
même les pharmaciens vont pouvoir
contribuer à cette campagne de
vaccination pour l'ensemble du
territoire tunisien encore faut-il avoir
assez de doses pour la population ces 12
millions d'habitants des dons continuent
à arriver un don de 500 mille doses est
arrivée sur l'aéroport de tunis carthage
en provenance du qatar d'autres pays
notamment comme l'egypte ont livré déjà
du matériel médical et pris la france et
manuel mabrouki a déclaré que huit cent
mille doses de vaccins ainsi que du
matériel médical sera libre et à tunis
la tunisie qui qui dévore vraiment
qu'ils essaient de gérer au mieux cette
crise mais un gouvernement qui semble
complètement dépassés par la situation
et d une association d associations
société civile des citoyens et surtout
le personnel soignant et qui demandent
vraiment au gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités pour enfin sortir de
cette quatrième vague meurtrière en
tunisie merci ben hassen chébili en
direct de tunis